hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen but
tonight I'm watching eight crazy nights
I'm dressed up as Whitey's sister
Eleanor because the other female
character literally looks like a
knockoff Belle from here yeah eight
crazy nights came out in 2002 and I was
God was I ain't seen your high when that
came out 2002 no yes No
sixth seventh grade swear I was I
haven't seen a lot of Adam Sandler films
just out of hearing they were terrible I
saw like happy gilmore and I think oh
happy gilmore I did Jesse his Netflix
special though which I thought was super
honest very endearing some really funny
moments also some really touching
moments I usually watch the Tamara's
never seen movies off of Amazon so I can
buy them or rent them for $3 and this
one had the list of the cast and it just
gave me three names the Christmas movie
trio you've all been waiting for
Adam Sandler Rob Schneider entire base
wait what Christmas movie trio then
everyone's been waiting for
Oh Tyra oh girl alright let's just get
into this one not not very high hopes
huh okay
[Music]
you
put these on to hide from from that
camera chambers reviews eight crazy
nights I didn't hate it didn't love it
gonna get out of this film I did not
think I was gonna enjoy any aspect of
this movie and the opening really did
not accept me it's just filled with
gross nasty toilet humor and I feel like
such a prude for saying that but guy
it's not funny to anyone does anyone
find that funny maybe in 2002 but not
today
Zerg sorry that was last week with Tim
Allen it opens on a burp joke but uh uh
Nate Davey who is voiced by Adam Sandler
he also voices like everyone else's
money
Davi is voiced and also pretty much
drawn after Adam Sandler JB is a
delinquent who doesn't like Christmas or
Hanukkah because parents died bah humbug
and also the hum hum but the Hanukkah
version of Bob dreidel
oh he also pumps his car that's fun
that's fun that's fun that's fun he also
farts moons people punches a woman's leg
gives her a raspberry squeezes of
women's watermelons just rude it's once
they've been squeezed they're not good
watermelons not melon melon
he's a song in the beginning where he
says sings sorry sinks I hate love I
hate you I hate me that's fun it's just
Christmas fun alright sorry on what
you're talking about that's just
Christmas fun then just go to next week
where I watch Muppet Christmas Carol
with Michael kine please so Dan he is
doing all this crap stuff in this crap
town buddy crap dates and he's about to
go to jail because they've had the last
of him and then whitey comes in with his
all fur ass it's like no let him
co-coach with me and then the judge is
like fine but if he messes up his Co
coaching thing he goes to jail for ten
years it's like all pretty much you get
the whole gist of the story in two
seconds
it's all very predictable very shit like
toilet humor and somehow it finds Hart
okay I'm getting ahead of myself ah
so why he takes Daisy to the mall
basically just to get a sense of
Whitey's character it's not really
furthering the plot at all then we get a
very short commercial for Sbarro and
Dunkin Donuts and Victoria's Secret and
sharper image and GNC and the body shop
and a bunch of other places and just
kidding nothing in this movie is short
then you meet Davies former love
interest from when he was in high school
of course she's single now and has a kid
haha what if what's gonna happen there
look what's the mystery it's a mystery
it's definitely gonna catch us off guard
not be obviously and then I realized
that okay fine fine fine I kinda like
whitey sumia okay whose house is really
cutely decorated and he loves Christmas
and his sister is probably the best
character in the entire movie and he
volunteer coaches and he works odd jobs
just to support him and his sister and
no one respects him and
dreams of just getting this one
Christmas award in the town
that's voted for by the town and it's
like yeah ok fine it's very obvious and
I can just sucker for this kind of shit
I like him ok
give it the award I swear to God if you
don't give him that award oh okay
and then David tosses whitey down a hill
in a port-a-potty was this funny in 2002
no rights rights no smell you later
poopsicle no that was such a Doug face
no that's probably the lipstick that
does it so whitey brings him to the
basketball court of course the woman
that he wants to have sex with son is
there and him and the son team up and
they play some guys at basketball
turns out Davey's amazing a basketball
which is interesting because he drinks
like a million years a day and hates fun
so these things is not like the other
he's nice to the son go and they win the
basketball game and I wonder if he's
gonna get to have sex with his mom now
so to further the plot of the movie the
guy that they effortlessly defeat at
basketball
his pissed and he goes and he likes
Davey's trailer on fire and everything
Wow everyone's super cool with it no one
calls the cops no one gets in trouble
just casual arson so Davy goes and lives
with whitey and his amazing sister
Eleanor do people would put fetishes
like this movie so I mean uh yeah at
this point I was really getting into it
yeah okay it's predictable the story is
very predictable and let's say humor is
let's say super not my thing and you
know I don't enjoy toilet humor and I
don't love predictable plots but if it's
gonna be predictable at least you know
give it some heart and they do and if
it's not cat the Hatter son of the mask
so okay fine I'm kind of getting it too
it's soo Miah everyone is gonna hate
this look am I giving up my
movie-watching card for this I've
already given that up who's kidding
ourselves okay they're all three
becoming friends
Eleanor whitey and Davey and he's
rapidly becoming a better person
very realistic that all comes crashing
to a halt when why he tells his sister
Eleanor the story of how Davey was so
good at basketball when he was in high
school and then his parents died
tragically in a car accident but somehow
left him a note then Davey gets mad he
doesn't want the story told and then
he's really rude to whitey and then
they're not friends anymore Davey gets
very drunk out of anger breaks into the
mall for some reason and then all of the
brands that I mentioned in the beginning
I'll suddenly become alive some reason
and sing a song to Davey telling him
that he needs to open up and finally
read the note that his parents left him
before they died what though I take back
saying that this was okay it's not and
I'm sorry I apologize
give me my movie-watching card back okay
the brand's opened the Hanukkah card
that his parents left him it's not even
that big of a like a rebel
it's just kind of like oh we love you
never change and it's silly and it's
sweet and it's fine it's whatever I
think this was supposed to be a
tear-jerking moment definitely didn't
make me cried don't worry I cried don't
worry just like he runs back to
apologize to whitey whitey does not win
the award and then I started crying
that's what he deserves little bored
give this animated little furry man in
oh and then he dejectedly leaves the
award ceremony Davey comes in and starts
singing a song about how wide he does
deserve the award and honestly the song
was pretty funny he got me with the bum
did he bum bums and okay ya know fine
maybe I was just worn down at this point
then I wrote giant giant letters holy no
I'm crying 1/8 crazy night then the
whole town shows up and he gets the
award more crying I'm just crying at
this point eight crazy nights the
animated Adam Sandler movie from 2002
helped Davey and the woman that he likes
end up together in like point three five
seconds and that's dumb as hell but I
liked this movie wasn't I not supposed
to like this movie I mean I didn't in
parts I didn't enjoy the toilet humor I
didn't enjoy how predictable it was but
again this was not the worst thing that
I've seen this year by by a long shot
it's gonna be that holiday movie air
about it right isn't that it right ah I
don't know guys I didn't hate this movie
and I'm sorry I'm sorry about it okay
alright just we'll move on together see
you guys next week back poops and farts
and butts and stuff you know Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
you